you've been working in politics and
media for for a long time and in the
past 10 years we've started to see this
this dramatic shift right you you worked
it's you worked at CNN right with
Anderson and now CNN they went
absolutely insane but they weren't like
that I'm telling you and people no I
know I look back and look at it Larry
King we covered all the legal cases and
political cases Anderson Cooper I've
always actually personally really liked
um we got along really well he recruited
me to come you know to CNN and they
weren't like that I worked with like
Wolf Blitzer and you know Lou Dobbs was
there at the time and it was like a
normal place it was actually kind of
cool you know to be there I used to
watch CNN I just have CNN on 24 7.
everyone did because it would give me
the breaking news and the breaking news
happened oh yes but CNN Headline News
too but then one day I noticed all it
was was panels talking about Donald
Trump I know and I switched to Fox and
it was Iranian protests I switched to
CNN Trump switched to Fox terrible
weather coming your way storms and
disaster Fox News extreme weather center
I I got to ask you for a lot of people
who have only seen this from the outside
I'm wondering what was your experience
inside watching this weird polarization
and the shift happening not just in in
news but in politics especially
considering your work in San Francisco
yeah you know it's so interesting
because I was for I was first lady of
San Francisco right because that like
we're not going to try to hide this it's
like on the internet but I was married
to Avenues and was the governor but at
the time San Francisco wasn't even that
bad then before a DA's office was good
mayor's office was good San Francisco
was clean it wasn't like your right
privilege and you get like you know gold
medal to like defecate on the streets in
front of kids like it wasn't you were
you were married to the man clearly
there was something good and and that
you saw in all of that that's not there
anymore okay well yeah I saw somebody it
was very hard working and actually
really cared about people and really
embraced the idea of being a public
servant like I did working for the
District Attorney's office and trying to
do good and do something incredible for
the community and that all involved you
know I actually been up Law and Order
and making sure there was not like chaos
in the streets that they were safe that
communities were safe the children could
walk to school that you know people
could you know raise their kids in
different communities you could invest
and buy something that added and in any
increased in value Right Live your
American Dream all the above San
Francisco absolutely beautiful place we
did care not cash Gavin Newsom did that
what was that well so care.cash was we
are not going to subsidize addiction and
poly substance abusers by sitting there
and giving them cash to just feed their
addiction and kill them to just
essentially be an accomplice to take a
life to actually try to battle back to
give people
um you know drug counseling treatment
get them clean help them with getting a
new job helping to reunite family
reunification uh whether you know if
they ended up in the court system
Etc we'd have drug court and help people
actually through the process and care
about them instead of just like throwing
a buck at it and saying your life isn't
really mattering to this community we're
just going to put you to the side for a
second here et cetera et cetera so my
question is with all of those good
things you are seeing and doing did you
actually witness the brain slug enter
Gavin's ear and take take over his mind
and turn him into whatever it is he is
today sad figuratively right but maybe
literally I don't know it couldn't have
gotten through the jail the gel but how
did how did he go from I'll tell you
because there was a whole movement that
became this super like liberal left like
woke agenda that is extremely persuasive
and aggressive and if you're not going
to stand on principle like they'll
they'll tsunami over you they will
destroy you I literally had people
coming to my house where he and I lived
protesting lighting sofas and on fire in
front of our house I would have to go
out there with the hose and I didn't
care I was like you're gonna come to my
house like now you're doing an
aggressive act against me and now it's
you and I let's go so I'm like ho like
shooting the hoes at people they're
ringing my doorbell all hours of the
night they're like Gavin Newsom doesn't
care about anybody he's like Attila the
Hun you have no idea the narrative was
so different he was the most
conservative person and moderate like
responsible about taxes is and
incredible programs for small businesses
all the above then we saw people come in
like the quote Bicycle Coalition you
cannot believe the power of the very
vocal minority that comes in with their
really weaponized agenda and how they
will spend their entire lives to destroy
you and try to make a point across so
that they become the loudest noise that
you cater to and I've seen it happen
over the years and we've seen this with
the woke media what's gone on and you
see it also quite frankly with um you
know the mainstream like corporate
weaponized media now doing the exact
same thing and it's just happened you
know one vicious cycle after the next I
will say probably the ascendancy of
Donald Trump help feed this in that
people became so upset so deranged so
obsessed and like addicted to Donald
Trump and Trump's Arrangements into I
think it's a thousand percent real we've
seen it at across all the different
election things campaigns events all the
above that literally they're like we
have to move like in unison against this
one you know entity dangerous like force
and movement in the country and so it
was just a complete slingshot of
aggression back in the other in the
other way you know to try to stop it
California orders skilled nursing
facilities to accept coronavirus
patients from the LA Times April 1st
2020. I don't understand how when you
look at Newsome Cuomo I think wolf uh
who what what other was it uh Murphy was
that one of the governors
um Whitmore Whitmer Whitmore they were
put in covid patients into nursing homes
and killing the elderly and and new
Newsome is one of the governors
not a listen um it's it's very upsetting
to me you know he and I still have
actually a very good relationship I've
had to clear up a few things
um recently with him and he enjoyed a
very good relationship with Donald Trump
even went so far as to say promises made
you know Promises Kept when uh djt went
out there you know for California for
the fires he went out with Jared Etc
um giving relief there happy you know
working cooperatively together but now
you find themselves on more kind of like
Polar Opposites there's a whole looming
election there's the chance if Biden
runs there's Kamala as Gavin Newsom
going to run so it becomes obviously you
know incredibly complex let's see if my
ex-husband runs against my future
father-in-law I don't want to just keep
popping on him though I'm curious about
you know what what was this cultural
shift in media and across the board that
I mean just to elaborate on the
experience for for for me when I started
working advice I wanted to be there
because they were edgy because they were
not establishment Shane Smith the CEO
had gone on Colbert and said look we're
not left not right we don't want to do
anything we just want to tell these
stories and then within a few years I
saw the transformation happening I'm
like I'm getting out of here and then I
went and worked for another company that
was new and then within eight months
boom they were getting woke of course
they went broke let everybody off I'm
just I'm just curious your perspective
on how this how this happens to these
companies I mean I I think you know okay
I'll tell you this because I also had
worked at you know MSNBC but like
filling in doing analysis and um you
know filling in like Prime Time anchor
like for Danny Abrams I was part of his
show
everyone was trying to kind of do the
same thing right except Fox yeah was
definitely more conservative for sure
but they're not even that conservative
these days to begin with you know what I
mean Tucker's fantastic I think like the
five I mean whatever but um MSNBC made a
you know conscientious decision from a
management perspective to go ahead and
be the counter programming to Fox News
that's what happened first in terms of
the big you know cable news networks
then seeing the success that MSNBC was
having in the counter programming like
you have to remember back there were
nights like Rachel Maddow you know Urban
everybody doing incredibly well in the
ratings like giving Fox a run for their
money okay and we were like you know the
the you know engine that couldn't fail
were like propelling for with like
smashing ratings then CNN saw what was
happening with MSNBC and decided they
would follow suit so then you had
someone like Jeff Zucker who was super
Trump The Apprentice everything you know
besties at weddings together you know
all the above come in and try to push
CNN to that extreme when you know Don
Lemon then Don Lemon uh you know Cuomo
who by the way I worked with at ABC News
and Good Morning America was not this
person that was like a super leftist or
anything like that but it becomes that
reward you know what I mean it's like
classical Condition it's like okay I'm
gonna do this oh it actually worked out
well I'm going to continue to do that so
you saw CNN do it but they relate to the
game that failed for them as an economic
model okay and it didn't work it didn't
ring true they weren't able to
capitalize on it and you saw their like
online thing the CNN digital total
collapse no infrastructure no
authenticity and then layoffs Zucker got
all of the above so CNN's in a free fall
with like horrific ratings right now
right it began to like drop down with
MSNBC you had the pandemic you had Trump
you had all these movements and you had
the mainstream media the print
journalism also being very aggressive
um trying you know following through
with that to say like this is not what
we want and making all these constant
attacks and attacks then you also saw
the political process weaponized against
conservatives against Trump with all
these different investigations that
later out turned out to not bear any
fruit right but it's actually what paid
for them to continue editorially to go
after him and demonize it's a
self-fulfilling prophecy they're making
it happen right the only reason anyone
was interested in pursuing it was
because they were getting pressure
because the media was it was a swirling
toilet it was a flush sending us down
into a into the sewers of you know
politics you advise your advisor to
Donald J Trump yes senior advisor what I
got from looking at it now looking back
is that he came in and without even
realizing it posed a threat to this
change of guard from the liberal
economic order to the new world order
that they're trying to create where
they're they don't want American
military bases they want to create some
Global technocracy and he wasn't part of
the establishment it seemed like he
didn't know that he was in the way like
he ended the trans-pacific partnership
which I thought was a brilliant move for
American sovereignty so now these
Malaysian oil companies can't sue us as
Citizens and he killed NATO accountable
but that pissed off this this oligarchy
that wants to transition did he know
that he was doing that or was he just
doing what he thought was the best for
the country I'll tell you something and
he actually he does what he thinks is
best he'll listen to your opinion your
Viewpoint he'll make a decision but um
he actually will analyze it and decide
but he operates from a businessman's
prism and perspective so you know and we
haven't really had like real businessmen
you know occupy we certainly don't have
one right now he doesn't have any
business experience Joe Biden right we
see what's happened with the economy and
whatnot but Donald Trump approached it
like that he's like well why are we
giving all this money to these people
they're not paying why are we giving all
this money to Nato they're not
contributing anything why are we giving
this money to China why are we doing
this and this and this and he actually
asked the questions like why are we
doing this and then he would get the
answers and then you know decide what
needed to happen in order to represent
America's interest he doesn't apologize
for being someone that represents the
United States and what our best interest
is for the American economy for
manufacturing for infrastructure uh you
know creating jobs and Economic
Opportunity across the board taxes Etc
and you know but he he operates from a
different perspective he looks at it
like what makes sense to me and I'm not
just going to do it this way because the
establishment left to right has been
doing it this way forever it seems like
he posed a threat to this transition of
order and so they were like crap we
can't tell people that he's a threat
because they don't know that we're doing
this we're doing it kind of undercover
they don't know we're transitioning from
the liberal economic that we're selling
out the American power structure to
create a global power structure right
just like the Paris climate change
Accord all the above that was like Hey
all the good old boys let's all play
ball bro let's we're all for the
environment blah he's like what the hell
why are we paying into this you know
what are we doing for that about Jesus
he's like China's the biggest polluter
and they're not paying the time why are
we paying all this money and kissing
everybody's ass he goes get that it
looks like that's how he talks he's like
this is no way it looks like what
happened is they were like introduced
okay he's a problem we don't want to
tell people why introduce identity
politics and then he bit and he fell
into it and he started talking about
leftism and I'm like I disagree well
actually didn't he not start getting
traction during the campaign until he
started tweeting more more stuff like
that he started tweeting out leftism in
2017. okay it was that I think that what
happens is the culture wars started just
slightly before Occupy Wall Street
Occupy Wall Street absorbed a lot of
this stuff good point and then you got
gamergate in 2013 and so a lot of people
started experiencing this this cultural
phenomenon this shift I went to a trump
rally in I think it was in Wisconsin
somewhere and I asked some older folks
uh I don't mean old but you know 50 50s
and these guys were like look Trump's
talking about bringing jobs back he's
talking about helping the union guys
talking about helping the working guy
securing our borders I'm all for it and
then I talked to some 20 year olds and
they were like he's against political
correctness and I respect that he speaks
the way he wants to without fear of
censorship and we're really worried
about what's happening culturally I
think that greatly benefited Trump both
are true early on and so I don't think
it's that he decided hey I'll use this I
think he was the Avatar of the Rage of
the working class and those who were
sick of the hoity-toity political right
just left this culture forgotten men and
women that were left behind which is
true they were left behind by both
parties and he makes that very clear and
I saw that when I went to Florida a
woman told me I asked her uh I was at
the it was a I was in Fort Lauderdale I
can't remember exactly which rally it
was
and I asked this woman I was like so are
you you're here to support Trump are you
a Republican Joe's oh no I've never
voted right and I'm like this is the
first like yeah she's like I've never
cared for it but he's finally speaking
up and the reporting at the time in 2016
was that areas of the country that
traditionally weren't really democrat or
republican were lighting up and turning
Republican because finally someone was
speaking to these people so here what I
think right now is to go on on what you
were saying Ian about that I'm relatable
absolutely and to to elaborate on what
you were saying about the threat to this
this order
I think you've got elements of the US
government that want the US to fail
Donald Trump gets elected and I think
you know his whole strategy is here's
how we're going to help America survive
and rebuild it and that's a problem for
those who have investments in foreign
countries I'll put it this way you got
these guys in government who have
effectively put put options on the US
economy yes and Donald Trump is now
jeopardizing their bet against America
by making it stronger and it's making
these people very poor they're very
angry about it I got the feeling that he
didn't realize that that he was doing it
that he was threatening some secret
transition I don't know if he knew I
don't think he knew I just it's felt
like he was just doing what he thought
was the best for the country from the
base I think he knew that it was going
to piss all those people off because
they certainly called and complained a
lot of people he knew he had people on
both sides and believe me they call and
talk to him and whatever but at the end
of the day like you're one thing you're
not gonna do you're not going to be able
to successfully like Bully Trump you're
just not he doesn't care he's going to
do what he but thanks he tells you
exactly what he thinks and he's gonna do
what he says that's how he is and
sometimes it may be frustrating like
whoa wait we got a win here like don't
say anything else about that you're
never going to win that conversation
with him because he's always going to
save it trust me but if you know he's
always going to react away you can use
that against him and get him to do what
you want I think I think he is
unpredictable we really I agree I do
agree with that predictable one thing
that was he'll change his opinion
believe me he could be in here right now
and you could say something to him and
he's like
and he said think about it then you
could come and say something to him and
he's going to think about that and then
you're going to see where he comes down
on it it's and you can't imagine like
whoa I didn't see that come why didn't
he go this way on that or blah blah blah
blah and he has the way he processes and
he thinks about things and he's a very
confident person meaning he knows what
he wants to do what he thinks and he's
going to do ultimately it doesn't matter
what he thinks is right in his mind
hello and thanks for letting us cycle
analyze you on TV is he going to win in
2024 I think so yeah I especially think
with everything that's like transpired
now what's going on with the
investigations with the District
Attorney's Office coming after him
whether it was you know Mar-A-Lago and
the insanity insanity and I remember
that night so well
um of them coming in and you know
storming Mar-A-Lago like how insane is
that and you're going through like
melania's closet like what is wrong with
these people like seriously seriously if
they can do it to him guess where they
can come in
I love your side in the front no
trespassing yeah
you better have a warrant I was like I
like this I mean but it's true right I
mean this is America and that you have
to stand up for what you believe in and
if you think it's okay that they're
gonna do this it's time and time again
on President Trump and like where's the
evidence where's the evidence of any of
the wrong doing and then it's Joe Biden
is sitting there living his best
Corvette Summer with a you know box of
docs in the garage with like crackhead
Hunter and like China like four you
couldn't make this up people be like
whoa whoa they'll be like what
medication are you on that you wrote
this script because no one will believe
it no one believe it but it's actually
happening in this country I do worry
that enough people are even getting this
information the amount of people that
didn't hear about Hunter Biden just
because of the media's ability to
censorship to censor it or to prevent it
from coming out at a politically
expedient time uh I think the biggest
uphill battle isn't just
um they did that to affect the election
yes
the New York Post just tweets on Hunter
Biden and now how many years we're
finding out it was actually true there
was like veracity and you know truth to
it there was evidence to back it up
there's evidence of foreign dear links
there's evidence of you know uh being in
bed with China and you know a million
dollars here there whatever I'm like
come on I mean come on and why is that
guy still running around thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time